the government is adamant the new school
year will not see the nationwide
closures of the last
and as priorities go the chief medical
officer says it's the right one
because children are at very low risk of
getting seriously ill
they're not zero but they're incredibly
small the chances of many children
being damaged by not going to school are
incredibly clear
and therefore the balance of risk is
very strongly
in favor of children actually going to
school
because many more are likely to be
harmed by not going than harmed by going
even during this
pandemic to address the concerns some
parents and teachers still have
the chief medical officers from all
parts of the uk have published a joint
statement setting out what they believe
will be the wider
impact of reopening in it they say
teachers are at no more risk than the
general working age population in most
workplaces
and the transmission between staff is
more likely than from pupils to teachers
the statement also accepts schools
returning will likely put upward
pressure on transmission in the
community
but says that will likely be an indirect
effect of more people returning to work
and increased use of public transport we
are going to
bring households together who would not
otherwise have been together
some of it directly some of it
indirectly through
for example allowing people to go to
work and the result of that is it will
create
some upward pressure on the r it may
increase it
we have still got a really serious
challenge
of chronovirus for at least
the next nine months and going into
winter we're going to have
real problems with this virus that is
what's worrying the head teachers union
who wants schools to reopen but believe
the government needs to be clearer on
its plan b
if there is the need for a local
lockdown like we've seen in germany this
is good this week
like we saw in scotland the first week
of schools opening we need to learn from
those examples
of who do we communicate with how do we
do it how do we make sure we can
reassure as many people as possible
in the london borough of newham an area
particularly badly hit in the first wave
of covid19
most people we spoke to accepted the
need to see schools reopen
do you think it's the right time given
the pandemic and coronavirus yeah i
think the right time yeah yeah
definitely i mean
shouldn't have been off for this such a
long time
i prefer to see the pubs close and the
schools open i
work in a hospital i'm a nurse so its
virus is actually gone down
so people are scared and i can
understand their fats
but the children are the future
certainties have been few and far
between over the course of this pandemic
but when it comes to the issue of
schooling the uk's chief medical
officers are in
no doubt they say the certainty of the
damage done to children by not being
at school outweighs any potential risks
of getting them back into the classroom
but balancing risks is different from
eliminating them
and while that's the case reassurances
can only go so far
tom rayner sky news westminster